CONDIONUK ECONOMY?BRIOMCERTAINE
>>UTTENONSENSE.
AT YOU'VE GOBIAT
AROUND THE WORLD.
PELEOOKINGTH--
TO SEE WHA
, IFMULATIVE GROIN THE
EUROPEAN6 TO
B FOUR LF PERCE
NVDON'TLK ABORI POLITICST? I HOH
MEMBER OF YO FAMILY WHEN
THER
ABOUT THERNE TH IS A SUBJT  WEE
THT.
A BRILLIATHWAS EW
ATOU
NI BUDORLIKE WHEN  THE PTHNOND
Y OKAY.
T E RIGHT TIME.
RET INK THAT MIGHT
G THE STANDARD QUESTN VING IT
T SOME
TWE I? YES
YOU TNSICI' AVEN.
S SARS,
OF ME
MYBEINPITATED
BY A FRISBEE BNDGNEDA DISU
ALOT BECOMINMIE
SQD. O T
DIFFERENTLY?
EAME OE THINGS THAT WE DID.
VEE
UKWHATERI THINCOA D S REAL V
I E TH'VE DOE SHOULD'VMOTOY TR,A
TT NAGE THE PI THINTHONER.
W VERY, D TOY TO RUN THE COUNTO
N THIS WLE,
YOU KNOW?
WE HNUO
EN ELECTED BOR